you can follow the NFL Network's Daniel
Jeremiah on Twitter had moved this Styx
NFL Network providing live coverage
round two and three tonight they started
7:00 Eastern
well done last night that was a fun
watch Daniel appreciate it Dan and I
think if we want to throw our own
scouting Service we're on the same page
in terms of what the Browns should have
done yeah you agree with me you would
have gone darn old and chub yeah that
would have been one in four for me I
think you you got to get the quarterback
first and I thought d'Arnaud was the
best option and then you know pass
rushers at the top pass rush you're
staring you right in the face I like
Tim's old a lot but I wouldn't have
passed on Bradley Chubb okay but how do
the Browns what is their strategy
explain to me what they're doing with
these two draft picks well first of all
they're destroying the myths that John
Dorsey is all about traits which is what
we heard forever because they got to
undersized guys with the Parsee picks
but you've got to altra competitive kids
and you've got to guys you know you can
factor in the fact they both won a heck
of a lot so I'm sure that factors in a
little bit as well but no I I just think
you you had a chance to get Sam Donald I
would have done that and I would have
gone got the pass rusher what if the
Browns had taken shake one Barclay and
then taken whatever quarterback was how
do you think that would have played out
if Browns go say Quan Barclay and then
what happens to three and then what's
available at four for the Browns I think
it probably would have gone to say Quan
Berkeley Bradley Chubb Sam Darnell's and
then they'd be they'd be sitting there
at four and I think they probably would
have got Baker does that make more sense
yeah but I think if you were in love
with Baker which they obviously were
they didn't want you know they're the
most important thing was they come out
of this thing with their top
quarterbacks who they think has the best
chance to be successful and you had to
do that at one even though there's you
know probably a pretty good chance you
could have got them before I know we
loved to hand out grades here let's
start with strategy grades here who got
who gets your top grade from the first
round you know I would say Baltimore did
a nice job of moving around
anytime you can kind of move back and
get some value I thought you know they
wanted to go tight-end there was no need
for them to do that at 16 so they're
able to trade back get some assets and
get the Hayden Hearst who is still the
best tight end of the draft and then you
know having some extra assets allowed
them to come back up it's 32 and take a
shot on Lamar Jackson Jill Flacco's on
the clock right no question you know I'm
sure was probably an uncomfortable night
for him you know Lamar Jackson that's
gonna take some time he's not as
advanced as Shaun Watson was coming in
last year to take over that job one game
and I'd be very surprised if Lamar was
able to do that so early in the season
well this is what I wanted to know
though do you think that the Ravens had
the foresight to go let's bring in RG
three similar skills to Lamar Jackson so
when he comes in you have somebody who
can help him and this is gonna be
probably at least a two-year process for
him but or do you think that's just a
coincidence that they signed RG three
and then they got the opportunity to
draft Lamar Jackson it's a great point I
know they didn't bring an RG three to
teach him how to slide but you know look
I think having having something like RG
three there it now when you make this
transition maybe it's a year from now
you have two guys that you can roll this
and I think Mike even made the point
last night if you are going to move your
quarterback and run around a little bit
you better have another one so I think
it does make sense in some foresight
there to bring him in ahead of time and
I guarantee you you know as they were
kind of going through the scouting
process and started you know kicking
around the idea of Lamar Jackson I'm
sure that made the rg3 thinking make a
lot more sense
I like Rosen I think he's certainly a
gift for us you know that he's quotable
he's ready to go why did he fall you
know it's interesting we said to the
process that the Josh some people were
going to be fine with him and not have
any issues with him and and other people
just wouldn't feel comfortable with him
and that's you know maybe that is just a
personality thing but the other part of
it is just a number scheme we had so
many quarterbacks up in that top group
so when you have four guys you know I
think it's you look at the teams
need quarterbacks and some other teams
that viewed that they were close you
know to me when you look at the Giants
and you look at the Broncos they had
decisions to make about whether this is
a long-term view or whether we think we
can flip this thing around right away
and they chose to believe in the veteran
quarterbacks they have and then get
somebody to help them win right now and
that's what kind of pushed Josh down the
court talking to Daniel Jeremiah NFL
Network analyst NFL Network live
coverage rounds two and three tonight
they started at 7:00 Eastern if you had
to pick NFL Rookie of the Year today
your pick would be who can I go
defensive here I think Derwin James
Derwin James and Gus Bradley's defense
with that front that they have with the
Chargers I think is going to be
outstanding okay he would definitely be
my pick on the defensive side of the
ball and then on the offensive side of
the ball you know I still go psycho on
Barkley I mean he's the best player in
the draft they were awful on third downs
last year and I think he'll he'll help
solve a lot of those problems I think
it's gonna catch it Connor balls next
year more likely to go quarterback today
or over the weekend the Patriots are the
Giants who I'll say the Patriots this is
the Patriots sweet spot for quarterbacks
second third round I'll be very
surprised if we come out of tonight and
they don't have a quarterback also
explained to me with the wide receivers
Cowboys it it felt like you know you got
a need there and you got a couple of
these guys these wide receivers just not
that good this year
I don't know I don't know is that Dan I
just thought that there's not that much
difference between the guys you would
take last night versus the guys it'll be
available tonight so when there isn't
that gap or that distance between them I
think that's why they decided to go
ahead and wait a little bit and Lana
couldn't pass up you know taking Ridley
is that it was just too good yeah I mean
to me that's just kind of a best player
available you know and when you're
picking towards the bottom of the first
round it's because you don't have many
needs in here kind of afforded that
luxury to just take the best available
guy you know we kind of looked out maybe
they'll get an interior lineman or maybe
another edge rusher and I you know
obviously they had they had big grades
on Calvin Ridley and didn't anticipate
him being there but man I tell you
that's uh it's already pretty darn
explosive offense does another weapon
like that how surprised where your
Patriots went running back first round
yeah they surprised me every year but
the surprise to me wasn't that it was
the result penny was the second running
back to go that was the big surprise to
me yeah I was surprised at that too
because most of the the draft boards I
didn't think that he was the second
running back you know probably the
fourth running back but Patriots going
running back there what surprises do you
think we'll see rounds two and three
well I think you will see I think you're
still gonna see some movement there's
there's not much there's not much
difference from rounds two three and
four this year there's a big huge clump
of guys so it just comes down to
preference on what you're looking for so
I think we'll see some teams moving
around through and target guys I think
it'll be a pretty busy night from that
regard but Dan I got to tell you a quick
story real quick on the Lamar Jackson
thing before all around I you're always
talking to teams and you're trying to
get information and they don't say
anything right nothing so I called my
buddy
with the Ravens in here he can probably
kill me I told him and he's in the car
on speakerphone and I've worked with him
and he's a good buddy and so I would
never ask something they're gonna pick
but his sons in the car and he's in the
back seat and so it's under nine years
old and I'm on speaker and I go hey what
you guys doing because I just left my
son's little league game and I go hey
buddy how'd you do
oh I was 2 4 3 2 4 3 had a good day
how's your team doing eight games we've
only lost one who's your favorite player
in the draft the Louisville quarterback
I know wait so your source is an 8 year
old or 9 year old no use a 9 year old
and I told my buddy I said I want
reports that a veteran source informed
me the Ravens could be interested in the
large acts a child close to me has told
me that the Ravens are gonna take Lamar
Jackson I love that III think it's I I'm
rooting for him I think it's a sneaky
good pic for them and you know he'll
probably get maybe some situational snap
I'm gonna guess this year and that's an
organization that needs some pizzazz you
know it's just I think they've maxed out
with Joe Flacco but you know they're
gonna they're gonna have him at least
one more year but you know that that's
interesting that Lamar Jackson you know
coming back in best moment of the night
was what Ryan sees here without question
I mean Dan just I couldn't stop staring
at his eyes and they look at
determination he had yeah what he was
walking out on the stage it really did
gave me goosebumps man hey have fun
tonight as always and we'll talk soon
thanks man appreciate it that's Daniel
Jeremiah NFL Network former Ravens count
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]